안녕하세요, 여러분 모두 수업에 오신 것을 환영합니다. 제 이름은 데이비드 브라운입니다. 이 수업은 문법 수업입니다. 안녕하세요. 환영합니다. 수업에 오신 것을 환영합니다. 노르마 학생, 환영합니다. 안녕하세요. 감사합니다. 오늘 어떠신가요? 저는 잘 지내고 있습니다. 선생님은 어떠신가요? 저는 아주 잘 지내고 있습니다. 감사합니다.
노르마 학생, 주말 잘 보내셨나요? 네, 가족과 함께 좋은 주말을 보냈습니다*.
좋습니다. 훌륭해요. 아드님과 시간을 보내셨군요, 맞죠? 이름이 호세 파블로인가요? 네. 항상 저랑 놀려고 해요*. 그래서 집에서는 아들과 노는 것 외에는 아무것도 못 해요.
네, 정말 좋은 주말이었던 것 같네요. 이번 수업에서는, 노르마 학생, 주말에 대해 이야기하고 규칙 동사와 불규칙 동사, 그리고 그 둘의 차이점에 대해 이야기할 겁니다.
그리고 발음과 순서 부사를 사용해서 우리 주말을 어떻게 묘사하는지에 대해서도요. 여기 학습 목표를 읽어봅시다. 화면 잘 보이시나요? 네, 잘 보입니다.
네, 좋습니다. 여기 이 부분부터 읽으면서 시작해봅시다. 이 줄을 읽어주시겠어요? 과거에 대해 이야기하기. washed, went, ate와 같은 모든 과거 동사들을 보시죠.
끝난 사건들을 묘사하기 위해서요. 네. 그리고 다음 거요? 그리고 다음 순서. 이야기 순서 정하기. 특별한 단어 사용하기. First, then, next. After that, finally, 올바른 순서로 이야기하기.
명확하게 발음하기, -ed 동사 어미를 정확하게 발음하는 연습하기. 네. 그리고 이야기 쓰기. 개인적인 과거 사건에 대해 3~5문장의 짧은 단락 쓰기.
네, 좋습니다. 이것들이 오늘 수업의 목표입니다.
우리는 과거, 현재, 미래가 있다는 것을 압니다. 다른 활용형들이 있고 많은 학생들이 두 가지 이유로 과거 시제에 대해 상당히 어려움을 겪습니다: 첫째, ED로 끝나는 동사를 발음하는 여러 가지 방법이 있습니다.
그리고 또한 우리가 암기해야 할 불규칙 과거 시제 동사가 너무 많기 때문입니다. 아마도 200개가 넘는 불규칙 과거 시제 동사가 있을 겁니다.
그래서 우리는 기본 동사 구조가 기본적으로 동사 + ed라는 것을 알 수 있습니다. 그리고 그것이 단순 과거입니다. 그리고 대부분의 경우 그렇게 작동합니다. 그래서 우리는 그냥 끝에 ed를 붙입니다. 예를 들어, finish가 있고 과거형은 finished입니다.
기본 동사, 그리고 나머지. 여기 예시가 있습니다. 이 예시를 읽어주시겠어요?
현재, watch TV, 과거, yesterday, I watched* a movie.
네. 좋습니다. 발음 연습을 조금 더 해볼 겁니다. 스페인어 원어민에게 watched의 ch 소리를 발음하는 것이 어려울 수 있습니다.
하지만 해내실 수 있을 거예요. 걱정 마세요.
그리고 이런 예시도 볼 수 있죠. They play soccer. 그리고 과거형은 They played soccer가 됩니다. 그리고 이 경우에는 다른 발음을 들을 수 있습니다.
첫 번째는 /t/ 소리, 두 번째는 /d/ 소리입니다. 그리고 여기 또 다른 예시가 있습니다. 이 부분을 읽어주시겠어요?
She cooks dinner 과거형 she chicken dinner last night. (chicken -> cooked)
훌륭합니다. 그래서 기본 철자 규칙은 동사 끝에 ed를 붙이는 것입니다.
y를 i로 바꾸고 ed를 붙여야 하는 경우도 있습니다. 예를 들어, study는 studied가 되고, cry는
i-e-d를 붙여 cried가 됩니다.
하지만 대부분의 경우, 과거 시제를 만들기 위해 동사 끝에 -ed만 붙이면 됩니다.
네. 계속합시다. 계속하기 전에 저에게 질문 있으신가요?
아니요, 그냥 선생님께서 말씀하신 것처럼, 어렵습니다. 제가 영어를 배우기 시작했을 때 가장 어려운 부분 중 하나가 과거 시제였어요, 그 발음 부분 때문에요.
하지만 계속 연습하고 또 연습하려고 노력합니다.
이해합니다. 그리고 어려운 것을 하려고 할 때 약간 긴장하는 것은 정상입니다.
지금까지 정말, 정말 잘하고 계세요, 아주 훌륭합니다. 그러니 걱정 마세요, 노르마 학생.
네. 그래서 한 가지 어려운 점은, 말씀하신 것처럼, 이 모든 규칙 동사들을 아는 것입니다.
그래서 우리는 그것들을 암기해야 합니다. 이 다른 동사들을 암기하는 것 외에는 정말 방법이 없습니다.
물론, 우리는 그것들을 문맥 속에서 사용해야 하지만, 이 모든 불규칙 과거 시제 동사들을 정말로 암기해야 합니다.
여기 몇 가지 예시가 있습니다. go의 과거 시제는 went... eat의 과거 시제는 ate입니다.
have의 과거 시제는 had* see의 과거 시제는 saw, drink의 과거 시제는 drank, make의 과거 시제는 made입니다.
발음 좋습니다. buy의 과거 시제는 무엇일까요? Bought.
아, 네. 이건 어떠세요?
wake up의 과거 시제는 woke up입니다.
네. 그리고 우리는 be 동사의 이 활용형들을 기억해야 합니다.
그래서 규칙 동사뿐만 아니라, 때로는 과거 시제 활용형에서 완전히 다르게 보이기도 합니다.
그래서 be 동사가 있고, 과거형은 was 또는 were입니다.
네. 이것들은 불규칙 동사의 작은 샘플일 뿐입니다.
시간이 있을 때, 이 불규칙 동사 목록을 찾아서 사용해보시기를 정말 추천합니다.
과거에 대해 말할 때마다 그것들을 생각해보세요. 정확하게 활용하고 있는지 확인하시고요.
이것들 중 몇 가지를 테스트해봅시다. 그리고 계속 진행해도 될 것 같아요, 아주 잘하고 계시거든요.
go의 과거 시제는 went, have의 과거 시제는 had, drink의 과거 시제는 drank입니다.
좋습니다. buy의 과거 시제는... Bought?
와. 네. 발음이 정말 많이 향상되셨네요. 정말 감명받았습니다.
감사합니다.
네. 그래서 -ed로 끝나는 이 동사들을 발음하는 세 가지 다른 방법이 있습니다.
이전에 이것에 대해 암묵적인 연습을 좀 했었지만, 이 규칙들 중 일부를 이해하는 것도 정말 유용하다고 생각합니다.
-ed로 끝나는 동사를 발음할 때 우리가 내는 세 가지 다른 소리가 있습니다.
하나는 여기 이빨로 내는 /t/ 소리입니다.
다른 하나는 /t/ 소리인데, 이빨 바로 뒤, 치조융이라고 불리는 곳에서 납니다.
거기서 d-d 소리를 발음합니다. 그리고 id 소리가 있습니다.
그래서 이 성대음으로 시작하는데, 모음이 여기서 나옵니다.
그리고 입천장의 dip 소리로 끝납니다.
그래서 dip과 id가 있고, 이것은 마지막 자음에 따라 다릅니다.
그래서 예를 들어 watch의 마지막 자음 소리는 ch입니다. 반복, 반복, 반복.
그렇죠. 아주 좋습니다. 네. 그래서 watched? 이건 아주 어렵습니다.
Watched? Watched? Watched? Watched? 아주 좋습니다.
훌륭합니다. 그리고 look은. Looked.
Looks 아주 좋습니다. Stop은. Stopped. 그렇죠. 그래서 끝에 a /t/로 시작하는 소리는 없습니다.
그리고 d 소리가 있습니다. 입천장에서 나는 소리 기억하시죠.
그래서 play가 있고, 과거형은 /d/ 소리 기억하세요. 따라 해보세요.
아주 좋습니다. Played. Played.
좋습니다. 이건요? Opened.
훌륭합니다. 그리고 이건요?
Lived. 와. 완벽해요. 멋집니다.
그래서 이 규칙들을 암기할 수 있습니다.
오랫동안 연습하고 듣다 보면 얼마 후에 배울 수 있습니다.
하지만 만약 마지막 자음이 L, B, V, G, M, R, Z, 또는 J로 시작하거나 오히려 끝난다면,
끝에 /d/ 소리가 날 것입니다.
기억해야 할 가장 중요한 규칙은 마지막 자음이 "t"나 "d"일 때,
끝에 -id를 발음한다는 것입니다.
그래서 wanted가 있고, 마지막 자음은 "t"입니다.
wanted, wanted입니다. need의 마지막 자음은 무엇일까요? Needed.
그래서 D입니다. 마지막 자음은 D입니다. 그래서 needed이고 decided입니다.
Decided. 완벽합니다. 네. 그래서 끝에 id 소리와 함께 추가 음절을 더합니다.
계속 진행해도 될 것 같아요. 기분이 어떠신가요?
이게 쉬워 보이시나요, 아니면 좀 너무 어렵나요, 아니면 어떻게 생각하세요?
제 생각엔 아주 잘하고 계세요.
아니요, 편안합니다.